all right well welcome everyone for
coming out for
our 2022 spring chub fellowship with
hilary hahn
[Applause]
so i can't say enough how much of an
honor this is to be up here
introducing
uh hillary han to all of you it's just
been quite the journey in terms of
getting her here and now the day has
come so it is really really thrilling to
have three-time grammy award-winning
violin virtuous so hilary han with us
so before we begin today's conversation
i ask that you make sure you turn off
all your cell phones and refrain from
taking any photographs except for
official photographer
so that you don't disrupt today's
program and please don't record either
okay so
device is off
and i want to begin today's program with
a land acknowledgement today's chug
fellowship event sits on traditional
indigenous territories this includes
lands of the mohegan mohican mashintaku
piquat eastern piqua
de [ __ ]
golden hill gusset niantic quinnipiac
and other algonquin speaking peoples we
honor and pay pres respect to their
peoples of past and present
so my name is mary lou i'm a professor
in the department of history on the
program of american studies and also
affiliated with ethnicity race and
migration
i'm also the head of timothy dwight
college the home of the chubb fellowship
so as the head of timothy dwight or td i
have the honor of serving as the
custodian of our illustrious chubb
fellowship established in 1941 out of a
prior large donation for education
purposes
this was made in 1936 by hendon chubb a
graduate of the yale class of 1895.
since its establishment the chub fund
has adhered to the goals of providing
encouragement and aid to students
interested
in government and american public
affairs the fellowship initially aimed
to foster among our yale undergraduates
an interest in public service in local
and state affairs grew over the years to
include numerous distinguished visitors
in national and international affairs as
well as leaders in the world of the arts
and humanities
since the 1940s the chuck fellowship
lecture series has inspired generations
of yale students to undertake public
service and pursue leadership roles in
the hopes of creating a better world
today and for posterity
the fellowship has hosted four u.s
presidents
george h.w bush gerald ford jimmy carter
and harry truman and in recent years
we've welcomed a wide range of national
and international leaders including our
congressional representative the
honorable rosa deloro olympic ice skater
michelle kwan visual artist faith
ringgold environmental activist bill
mckibben physician and humanitarian dr
hawa abdi and world renowned actor
shahrukh khan just to name a few
so with this quick description of the
history and aims of the chubb fellowship
i'm deeply honored today to have hillary
han join the impressive list of chubb
fellows who have visited timothy dwight
college and yale
and today's event has particularly deep
significance as it marks the relaunch of
our chubb fellowship program after a
two-year disruption because of the
covet-19 pandemic
td has selected ms han to be our fall
2020 chubb fellow just before the
university shut down in the spring of
2020
and we have waited patiently for two
years and i heard that she's waited
patiently for two years
to come to campus and
join us in restarting our wonderful
chubb fellowship
we've always considered the chub as our
gift to the university and to the city
of new haven
so for today's chub event
i'm particularly grateful for the hard
work of my wonderful timothy dwight
college staff our student aids team the
support of yale college arts the school
of music and the yale symphony orchestra
for supporting our spring chubb
fellowship program
putting together a large-scale public
event is never simple and doing so under
covet 19 conditions is even more
challenging so thank you to everyone who
helped make this happen today i'm just
simply thrilled that we're once again
able to share the chubb fellowship with
the university and the city
so
with that let me get to our main event
so as a preschooler hilary hahn started
her musical studies with the suzuki
method violin lessons at the peabody
conservatory in baltimore
at the age of 10 she was admitted to the
curtis institute of music in
philadelphia
so all you people who are just starting
violin you gotta get a move on it
at 17 she recorded her debut album
hilary han plays bach to wide acclaim
and in 2001 she was named america's best
young classical musician by time
magazine
she is recorded with deca deutsche
gramophone and sony and her 19 feature
albums have all opened on the top 10 of
the billboard charts
she has won grammys for three of her
albums the 2003 brahms and stravinsky
concerto album a 2008 pairing of the
schoenberg and sibelius concerti and her
2013 recording of n27 pieces the hillary
han encores
hillary han is a great supporter of new
music in 2009 she premiered composer
jennifer higdon's violin concerto that
had been wit for her when the two first
met in higdon's class in 20th century
music at curtis
she premiered the higdon concerto with
the indianapolis symphony orchestra and
the piece was awarded the pulitzer prize
the following year
in addition to higdon she has
collaborated with a number of
contemporary composers commissioning new
works such as six partitas by anton
garcia abril and sonata number four
fractured dreams by lara auerbach
timothy dwight college selected miss han
to be our fall 2020 chub fellow in
recognition of her leadership in making
music accessible through her
performances and recordings
she has launched several exciting
projects such as her hashtag 100 days of
practice which we'll hear more about
using the instagram platform to inspire
musicians of all levels to play and
share in their experience of music
making she's also launched the bring
your own baby concerts to encourage
parents of infants and toddlers to share
their love of classical music and
relaxed and welcoming environment
and in 2014 han was awarded the glass
shoot original music festival award for
her quote ability to inspire young
people through the intensive and
compromising approach to making music
in 2019 she donated her 25 000 prize to
the philadelphia non-profit project 440
in recognition of their outstanding work
with the city's youth to ignite their
interest in music and harness music's
potential for individual growth and
community empowerment
for those reasons she is our spring 2020
chub fellow
so
her energetic and innovative leadership
in an expanding the world of classical
music is extremely welcome especially in
this present moment of 2022 so please
join me in welcoming hilary hahn
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's such an honor to be here thank you
for being here
together all together to celebrate this
and i'm looking forward to the
conversation and taking some questions
from the audience uh first i thought i
would play a movement of solo bach to
get us all grounded together
and then proceed
used
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey
[Music]
my
three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
so that was as you heard
you know we are so appreciative of you
and you're sure i'll take some water if
you're pouring yeah sure
no that was a beautiful performance of
box sarah bond and thank you
just really appreciative of you sharing
your music with us today so maybe one
more round of applause
[Applause]
so maybe just to start let's pick up on
bach i know it has clearly some very
special meaning to you it was your first
album that hillary han plays bach that's
quite a statement
but i'm just curious if you can tell us
more about your relationship to the
music of bach
yeah i started my recording career with
solo bach because
i was
16 and it was the music that i'd played
the most and it just felt like if i'm
gonna record something i should record
something that i've played a lot
and i'm really glad i did because
starting with a solo album i got to
learn all about the recording process
without the pressure of time we recorded
all night like multiple nights in a row
each piece had its own separate time of
the year like we really had the luxury
to
take our time and i got to learn about
recording i got to learn about playbacks
and
about like acoustics and
how it sounds different under the mics
from how it sounds when you're playing
for the audience so i really was working
with such an expert team and if i hadn't
started with that i think i wouldn't
have been
so inclined to be involved and these
days i co-produce my records i am
involved in every aspect sometimes i run
the sessions if it's a very small crew
sometimes i let the producer run the
session you know but i have so much
experience now and i'm really glad that
i i started with that but i will say
when i
first proposed that as the repertoire
for that first album
um
it felt very natural to me but back then
it was
back in the 90s 20th century
back then it was kind of taboo for a
teenager to be
playing bach or be
i suppose like projecting authority on
the music of bach or brahms or beethoven
it was sort of seen as like
further along in your career material
and pretty audacious and i think there
was a little pushback inside the record
company but i didn't know that
so i just went ahead and did it
but now
you know i think because i was so
convinced of my playing of it it was so
comfortable for me
and i enjoy the intricacies of it
it just comes very naturally to me
although it never feels totally natural
to play it but the ideas feel like they
make sense when i'm playing his music
i think because of that when i was the
like the teenager recording and
releasing bach it made it okay
later
so i definitely see people starting
their recording careers with solo bach
now and i'm like
you're welcome
but it was an honor to be able to start
with that
so when you we were walking in we were
playing your your
newer album
the virtuoso album yeah so lots have
changed in between
yeah that album is um it's called a
compilation and usually the record
companies put it together i think but i
actually put it together it's my
favorite
tracks from
a lot of my different albums um and my
favorites for different reasons like i
might have an emotional attachment to
one project
i might
remember working on this one with the
composer
or like this whenever i play it as an
encore it's a big
big hit and therefore i really feel like
the audience connects with it and so
when i listen to it i remember all those
great performance experiences
and so yeah that's that's what i was
doing with that record so how different
is
that newer record from the retrospective
record which we you did in 2018 now was
that something the record company put
together you curated that too i curated
that as well but i added some um some
tracks that i had performed live
and so yeah it was it's kind of nice
it's nice to go back
and look at the work that you've done
and
not have someone else pick out their
favorite things but really put together
it's like playlists on a really big
scale
and it's it's kind of surprising to me
because every time i do a project i'm
just doing that project and like when i
count how many records i've done
i'm like how did that all happen
um but it's just really chipping away at
things one one little part of a project
at a time and having ideas that i follow
through on
so i noticed that between the 2018
retrospective and the 2020 virtuoso
there's some repeats so clearly these
are some of your favorites right can we
talk about some of them how did they
become some of your favorites like um
like the paganini concerto i think is
one and the higdon concerto must be
another one
uh how do i
de-de-tangle the threads
um
i actually i i don't know if like
i think of sort of like the overarching
experience like i think when i'm
thinking about my favorite tracks from
records
it's more like i listen to them but it's
the context in which they occur
so
there are pieces that i learned with my
teacher and pieces that i taught myself
you know and there's there's all sorts
of different transitions there are
pieces that i commissioned there are
pieces there are projects that i started
and
um i think with
with paganini you know it's it's such
virtuoso music but i find the beauty in
the phrasing i kind of like looking at
something that
is thought of one way and showing that
it's actually much more complicated than
that there are many other aspects
that exist
and the same with a commissioned work i
don't like to look at it as just let's
play the notes and get it out there it's
really how can we already work to find
as performers whoever the combination of
performers is for this particular
performance how can we find our
um
our interpretation to really bring this
music across to the audience as a
complete piece if i think about what
brahms would have sounded like to
a new audience
if the performers had no idea of
phrasing traditions
and then i make that leap in my head to
what we assume now of brahms with all
the traditions we know the structure
we've heard a lot of those works a lot
that's my job in a new piece my job is
to like do that leap and get it to the
place where there are clear phrases
where the music
can really speak to the audience not
just play it through and say it's a
premiere but really like
really make it a whole experience for
the audience because when it starts that
way it can then evolve as other players
pick it up
if it i believe like the energy you put
into
any piece that you play but especially
the first performance of a piece kind of
sets it on its journey and if you give
it a big good shove away from the dock
you know you're like yes
and it's all set to if it's a ship it's
like all set to sail um
then
that is really i think the best thing
you could do for a new piece of music
okay can you describe that in terms of
uh or go in a little more detail about
that in relation to the jennifer higdon
piece
so i met jennifer as you mentioned in
the um
let's see how old was i was like
15 i was 15. so it was the mid-90s and
she had just graduated from curtis
and she hadn't yet
become like inundated with commissions
but it was coming she was getting busier
and busier
and
i was her student
she was a really enlightening teacher
she taught 20th century music history
and brought it from
you know like
the very beginning of the 20th century
all the way into the present day
each week we learned about
one or two
new composers that we hadn't studied
before and the way she would teach she
would put um
just like some key words on the board
and then we'd listen
and it wasn't teaching the
facts about a composer it was teaching
the ideas
teaching us what to listen to
how to listen how to pick things apart
but not in in an analytical way but more
of like an emotional connection to what
we were hearing and defining that for
ourselves and there were some facts on
the board too but we were never quizzed
on those we were quizzed on how
we related to the music
and i think that was a great way to get
to know her as a composer
because she is very she's very specific
in her music like she really wants the
score to be like she writes
but she doesn't write anything extra
that she doesn't need to have in there
and the music has a lot of energy and it
can it communicates
immediately it's almost clearer for the
audience than it is for the player
so my challenge with that concerto
has always been to embody it as much as
the audience hears me embodying it
it's very um clear music to listen to
but in the middle of it there's all this
stuff going on so you kind of have to
keep you have to keep your center
and
keep aware of all the cues but also the
momentum is super important in her music
so how much did you work with her
directly to kind of bring that music to
life
i like to leave composers b i like to
not have them second guessing when
they're writing and just write what they
want to write and then give me
what they feel
they've completed not like the final
draft i do like to see it
before they finalize it but basically
yeah i just try to
get the music
and
then we talk about things that may or
may not be so practical or
may or may not communicate the way that
they might be trying to communicate it
and then
i'm curious i mean several people have
now played it so
at this point so what do you hear when
you hear others playing that concerto
i haven't heard anyone oh you haven't
yet oh they play it but i haven't been
there oh yeah yeah
yeah i would love to hear it but um
i i think that the piece is it has a
very strong personality so i think it's
going to sound like the same piece no
matter who is playing it and having
recorded it i always try to record the
pieces that are written for me so
there's a document so that like
push from the dock is like a global so
that anyone who wants to hear it anyone
who wants to learn it there's a
precedent and they can just build on
that i find it a lot easier as a player
myself to have something to listen to
before i play a piece
so even if a piece is new newly written
for me i will make my own practice
recording and listen to it get it in my
head and that's how i developed my
interpretation i listened to what i did
and i think what would i want to do
differently from that player and then i
kind of develop it from there
i can't help but wonder if that's a
little bit of this early suzuki training
maybe
listening to the piece before you play
it or yeah maybe it could be who knows
um but speaking of new music you've
definitely been a big supporter of new
music and contemporary composers so the
um
the album 27 pieces for example is a
great example of that so i just want to
hear your philosophy towards
contemporary music what are you looking
for when you're asking people
to you know commission a work for you
i for that album
um i think i didn't
realize what i was taking on i got
really excited and i
i
commissioned a lot of people with a lot
of different styles
and i was thinking in terms of minutes i
was like okay i've done concerti i
hadn't commissioned anything shorter
than a concerto before so i was thinking
if i commission
if they're all like three to five minute
pieces
and i commission
10 will
so then 10 will feel like a concerto and
it'll just be like preparing two
or three concerti and i can do that over
time
and i didn't realize each piece is about
as much of a learning curve as an entire
concerto so it was learning
i'd only worked with two of the
composers before so it was learning the
style
and the intentions and the musical
language
of 27 composers and i are 26 and i did
an open contest for the final encore
which was always something i wanted i
wanted to like open it up have
accessibility for people whose music had
not yet been recorded that i may not
have come across
and i picked a winner out of nearly 400
entries that came in so when we received
almost 400 entries i
called a friend and i was like can you
can you just help like
sort through them because they were
supposed to be
blind entries and they didn't want
anyone to get disqualified because
they'd forgotten to take the title out
or forgotten to remove their name so i
had some people help me out just sort of
sorting through
the the contest so i had volunteers it
was really it was nice it was a big a
big project but doing that
it was important to me
to find composers whose music i felt
compelled to play like i was curious
when i heard their music i was curious
what
they
would write for violin and piano duo and
i just couldn't let it go so that's my
sign whenever i'm working on an idea
if i cannot let the idea go if i can't
stop talking about it um
even once i've convinced people they're
like yeah we get it we're on board
that's my sign that it's something i
have to do like i'm just not going to be
able to sleep on it and it'll fade away
and so that was how i approached which
composers i commissioned
and then people say yes right away
because i imagine if hillary han is
writing you yes is the answer
well one of them i i did a lot of cold
calls because i didn't know them so i
would get their number from
their agent or just
i don't know like a mutual friend or
something someone and um i'll give them
a call maybe their website
[Laughter]
and
one of them thought it was a student
prank calling so it didn't call back
so i called again and he was like oh
sorry it really is you
um but it was a lot of cold calls a lot
of hi
i'm hillary hung i'm doing a project
um do you think you'd be interested and
also i wasn't sure about the politics
like asking these great contemporary
composers to write short pieces for for
starters it's like there's a bit of an
issue sometimes with composers being
asked to write the first piece of a
program sort of like the
overture
or um
you know being asked to write short
pieces but it was really a statement
about the
like the span of contemporary styles
and expression through all of this range
of styles that's what i was going for
and so i was hoping that the composers
would understand like the scope of the
project but then i wasn't sure if they
would like being on a project with so
many other composers um
turns out they were all really
open-minded and supportive of each other
and it was really nice sometimes i got
to introduce two composers to each other
and just sit there like a post-concert
dinner they would both have come to the
concert because they both coincidentally
be in the same city and very different
people totally different styles of music
getting to know each other just made me
so happy to like introduce these
creative people and get to kind of
observe the experience so you didn't
really have people coming together
during the
writing process
and some of them i never have met oh
i communicated with them by phone
or in german
one of them
doesn't do email doesn't speak english
doesn't have a phone
and so his daughter
speaks german and lives in another
country and can communicate with him and
so he sent the music
and then i just kind of had a couple
questions about the score so i got the
answers like a game of telephone
and i was like okay i think the piece is
just going to play itself
and that's the thing when you're a
performer and you're working with new
music you are given the responsibility
of interpreting it bringing it to life
but there's also within that
responsibility a sense of
like judgment you have to use your
judgment to
figure out how closely you adhere to the
score how much you take on board what
the what the composer says and
ultimately it has to feel like the music
is in you and it's natural to you so
i always try to
get the composer's feedback maybe i send
them a practice recording
if we're in the same place i'll do a
coaching session with them in person
and then i'll try one more time if i if
i can i'll send them one more practice
recording to see if i interpreted what
they told me and have incorporated it in
a way that they're comfortable with
but it's definitely a it's a process and
you have to give over some of your
creative license
for a little while
um and then ultimately you know you have
to understand the personality of the
composer like one composer will write
rubato and mean it starts slowly and
goes faster and another will mean the
opposite and there's nothing to say what
they mean to them it's obvious so you
have to look at it examine every detail
and say now when you say rubato
what does that mean to you and sometimes
it's an emotional thing sometimes it's
very specific sometimes it's just oh you
just play it however you want to play it
it's really interesting and i i also did
a published edition for the 27 encores
one of the things i love about working
with composers is looking at the score
and just seeing how do they
how do they express their music and
writing
and
they were it was such a project because
they were doing
they were using all different software
programs they were using some some sent
in handwritten scores some had no bar
lines so where he put a rehearsal number
but it was conceptual like it was always
intentional um
and it always said something about their
creative process so in the addition at
first the first draft of the edition the
publisher
did house standards
for all of the
[Music]
markings you know like this is where we
put the slur this is where we put
dynamics you know not necessarily
replicating what was in the version the
composer turned in and i looked at it
and i said this doesn't even look like
the same piece we have to go back to the
drawing board and start we have to reset
all of these because they have to look
different when you flip through if a
composer was minimal it has to look
minimal if it was
a composer writing like
an like five instructions for every note
which i kid you not has is in one of the
pieces um
like everyone has to be lined up very
precisely we can't have any like
floating markings anywhere like if
you're gonna do a column of five it has
to be a column of five you know not two
on top three on the bottom like fit it
wherever because when you're playing you
have to look at it a certain way and
it's an experience of reading and
translating that to playing
um
and so that but that's like
anyone who works with me knows i put a
lot of attention into the details
because it's important like it's really
important when working with composers
because you're starting a document the
performance is a document
the how many times do we have
discussions in rehearsal about what
about the composer did they mean mezzo
forte here or piano if you're premiering
something and you do an edition you're
responsible in a way from making sure
if you know something about the piece
and you see that it's not showing up in
the score you have to put it in there
you know for the sake of the composer
because no one can get everything
right so
yeah speaking of documentation i'm just
curious how much social media like
youtube has really changed that so do
you feel like people know you and your
music through
recordings or more through youtube and
these days i'm just curious that's a
good question i think that people's
consumption patterns have changed
i used to be mad at youtube i'm not mad
at youtube anymore
why were you mad at youtube because um
almost everything on there was pirated
and people were very proud of spending a
lot of time watching and listening to me
on youtube
and it was they thought they were
supporting me but they actually
weren't like in a business sense
supporting me
um
and i would be trying to sell records
post concert and people be like i watch
all of your youtube videos and i'm like
thank you
but don't get me wrong i i just i really
appreciate the enthusiasm and i
eventually realized that that's not
really what youtube is about youtube
isn't about
business youtube for me like
the industry i'm in
the performances are
the business and the recordings
i
yes it's it is an industry it is a
business but
as far as the purpose the purpose for me
is having the music out there
as much as possible so when i record
something i'm recording it for a purpose
i'm not recording it because
i want to record my version i'm
recording it because i think there's
value in something i'm doing in it
existing out there for the sake of the
piece
and that's why i record all the new
stuff so then if it's on youtube if my
performances are on youtube if it makes
a difference in someone's life to watch
the youtube video it's great because i
can't be everywhere at the same time and
i do notice that students have grown up
watching my videos so it's a different
feeling for me now i remember watching
videos that were pirated when i was a
student and um but there were videos of
like heifetz ellen millstein
you know anything i could find that was
an older video
and they were really formative so i just
kind of i look at it differently now and
i appreciate the connective aspect of
social media including youtube
it's also evolved like youtube is
different it's a different experience it
has a different presence in people's
lives than when it started
yeah along the lines of recording and
promoting different composers i know
you've done a lot in terms of wanting to
promote um
female composers
composers of color so i want to just
hear more your philosophy about that in
terms of you know trying to open up the
world of classical music
um i think it was actually the 27
encores project that i'm thinking about
like when my philosophy on streaming
changed
because i noticed
that with
when i was listening when i was really
trying to find composers for the project
i really appreciated the streaming
services that would suggest the next
thing
and that wasn't necessarily the case
back when i was putting the project
together was about
over 10 years ago
and so what we take for granted in our
listening experience now is something
that has developed in my career in the
course of my career
and i was able to access composer's
music that wouldn't have been on the
shelf in the record store
through
google searches and
through searching
through various video
channels and also youtube and all of
that so i definitely at that point
that's when i let go of my
misunderstanding about the purpose of
streaming and
um i'm one of the artists who actually
is like you know what music is very
multifaceted
it's about reaching the audience and
it's about
people respecting the music so if that's
the if that's what's happening through
the experience people are
getting the emotional connection they
need and hearing the voices they need to
hear then that's what it's about and in
that same way
i've obviously
been
noticing gaps in my repertoire
i grew up in a time when
at conservatory we really didn't learn
new music at all
and
my teacher was born in 1907 so his
contemporaries were barber bernstein
you know the prokofiev
and
so i got the feeling of knowing as a
performer knowing a composer
but it was just not like
quite up-to-date at that time and now
it's a different experience for students
but i would say that
i definitely prioritized
um
i really tried with the 27 encores to
balance that project
i looked for
composers from different parts of the
globe
but i realized in re-examining
everything over the past few years
that i thought that i had good
representation in it and i didn't i had
definitely fallen into
bias gaps and i definitely had
not taken some things
on board that i should have taken on
board and so now
after
all of the racial reckoning after george
floyd's murder
i wound up just taking a step back
because i wasn't performing at the time
anyway so i took a step back and i
re-examined every layer
of my work
and i was like
where
am i
losing the thread you know which voices
are not present
how did that happen
what's going on there
how did i arrive at this point and how
could i like
go back and be more
inclusive have better representation and
i'm still obviously still learning it's
a lifelong thing
but
i re-examined all the projects i had
going i reshifted them
and so i think from now people will
start to see
like that
i am putting emphasis on representing
as many
voices as possible because i think
contemporary music and contemporary
musical projects are
[Music]
a place where
we can allow people to express their
lived experiences you know we look back
in history but we put things together
about mozart's life with current events
at that time
but everything being written now and
things being written by people whose
voices haven't been heard
those are the those are part of a
historical document about the human
experience so we need to have people's
experiences put into music and played
not every experience can be expressed in
words there are a lot of feelings put
into music that can never be in a
historical document
that um you know a lot of people will
watch historical films
to get the feel for what it might have
been like to live in that time or what
did people speak like back then or we
have performance practice i mean listen
so we need to keep that that musical
record going for the future for 100
years from now 150 years 200 years
so that people playing that music can be
like that's what it felt like to be this
person at this time
and no one is a monolith so we need to
take people as their full human selves
and allow them to say what they need to
say and get out of the way like
sharing the spotlight is not about being
in the spotlight with someone else all
the time like sometimes it's like giving
someone the spotlight and getting out of
it and so that's something that i've
been trying to do more of these days
so when are we going to see a new
project from you then
yeah
well i've already started premiering
some solo encores by composers of color
the reason i've been commissioning solo
encores
is because i have complete programming
freedom with them
the
short pieces i can play in every single
concert so i can play them with an
orchestra you know without the orchestra
when i would normally play solo bach i
can play a piece by a contemporary
composer
if i'm on the radio i have a tv
appearance if a piece is three to four
minutes long too long for tv but
i can
program it in a lot of short form
performances
it's just me and the violin so i can do
whatever so that's why i'm focusing on
that solo encore form which is something
that i missed with the duo encores
people would want to hear them
but there's no piano on stage after i
play with orchestra
i do a solo bach recital
there's no piano there so what do i play
as nagar or marcelo
[Laughter]
but
you know it's it's a really interesting
thing to look at the programming i don't
control most of the programs that i'm on
um
i'm a guest so what can i do and i think
that's also a theme of my career
what do i really have in front of me and
what can i do with it and how can i do
more than what i initially think i can
do so for example with the project 440
donation
i tied that to a larger fundraising
campaign so out of 25 000 we raised 50
000 so
you know looking at it like being
creative and making the most
out of what you have and then with that
they were able to hire a new full-time
person so it's kind of like
also with repertoire i look at it that
way you know when i have an opportunity
what can i do with that opportunity and
how can i
be helpful with that opportunity
that's great
so i
it you you're so so i did premiere
actually did so
there are two pieces there's one piece
by michael abel's that i premiered
during the pandemic and there's a piece
that i just premiered the other day by
barbara asikinak and she's an
anishinaabe composer
um who lives up north in turtle island
which is north america
and she wrote a lot of the indications
in the music in ojibwe but she also
trained in the hoshula in munich so
she's got a very avant-garde european
composition
tradition as well as
growing up in the bush and being a
nature guide playing native flute and
getting a lot of her ideas during
ceremonies
so it's really interesting you know i
think
we need to listen to the voices that are
creating
and
really
put things together in ways and programs
that
help us see a bigger picture
so as you're doing this i i know that
you also re-recorded or maybe
i say re-recorded as though you did it
before but but you recorded volumes one
books one through three of suzuki yeah
they've had several iterations of
recordings okay so i didn't record my
recording but i i re-record i recorded
a new version right at their an
invitation
so so what inspired you to pick that
project up
they asked me
and
it was nice i mean i was the first woman
to do an official recording for the
suzuki violin repertoire a lot of the
suzuki teachers are women so i i felt
good about that
but mostly just the
emotional connection
to suzuki because i started with it and
i remember all those pieces like when i
was in the sessions there's a
representative from suzuki who's there
as an expert because
i can't just play the pieces however i
want i need to keep in mind how the
students need to hear them for training
purposes and for
like speed i can't just take off and a
tempo
and zip through yeah
yeah i can't just be totally free with
all the rhythm and like do full vibrato
i mean i could but then it wouldn't be
helpful it would kind of be
counterproductive so
there was someone there as a sounding
board for those questions
um
and
sometimes i would have an instinct about
the rhythm and i'd say is this
should i wait and they're like yes yes
that's the tradition you just hold that
and then start the beat on the next on
the next note and that was just so
deeply embedded in me from having
learned that music a really long time
ago
so it was really it was very nice and as
i was recording i was thinking about how
these are the recordings that all the
little suzuki kids and their families
are going to be listening to in car
rides and car pools yeah
non-stop yeah
it was like it was really it was a big
honor you know because that's a big
responsibility but also really sweet
so i so i i just want to transition
maybe to some of your um less
traditional projects okay so in terms of
i think social media you have the what
hashtag hundred days of practice i
promised the audience we asked about
that
and i and you just told me you just
finished you just finished 100 days of
practice so so tell us a little bit
about that and maybe this will will
start to wrap it up and open it up to
the audience okay so it began for me as
a response to a visual art project that
i saw posted on instagram
and that the suggestion from the host of
that project was just to pick
um a topic that's like 100 days of
whatever but it's work in progress not
to post your finished work
but uh because there was at that time
with visual art on instagram there was
an issue kind of like of
people being
only posting their best stuff
and it being kind of like intimidating
to be there
in that scene
um and it was a way of opening up
the behind the scenes to be more public
and i like to draw for fun and i was
like maybe i'll just like draw for 100
days and like no one wants to see that
and i don't think i'll be drawing for
100 days if i start 100 days of drawing
so i thought i should do 100 days of
something
because i mean i desperately i wanted to
belong to this visual arts project
i was like the popular kid who's like
trying to
trying to be in the crowd and they're
like oh i'll just do this little thing
on the side maybe you'll notice me so
something tells me if you actually
posted a hundred pictures people would
look at that you would be saying look
you would be surprised it's interesting
um people are very into me playing
violin
people are very kind and tolerate my
other ideas but me playing the violin is
really what people are there for
um
and so i just wanted to kind of
participate in this project but in a way
that was natural to me and so i was like
i practice anyway i should i should
practice anyway so i'll just do that
and i didn't honestly think that anyone
would care or notice i thought if
anything it would be annoying because it
wasn't finished material and
we're not taught that practice is
something anyone wants to hear like if
anything we're taught that no one wants
to hear practice
and that we shouldn't be playing through
like a performance when we're practicing
it should be practice but it's not a
performance it's not for public
consumption and so i was just thinking i
better be ready with some like good
content after all this is over
for the people who stuck around
and i started getting feedback during
the first hundred days that it was
really making people feel comfortable
about their own practice
um and people thought it was very brave
of me to post my practice
but
i go on stage in front of thousands of
people and perform i was like there's
nothing
brave about like playing not
particularly well for the camera and
putting it up there like this it didn't
for me translate into an act of courage
it was like just something very
inconsequential i thought but seeing
that really made me realize
exactly how
isolating practice usually is and how
much pressure we're taught to put on
ourselves in practice i mean i equate
practicing as a student to
being told to stand in front of the
mirror pick out everything you don't
like about yourself and fix it all by
yourself
and then present yourself to a judge to
see if you got better
that's really what it is i mean you're
really
going into the practice room to find
problems with your playing
to figure out how to solve them the
problems are there because you don't
know how to fix them like how are you
supposed to fix something that you're
doing because you don't know how to fix
it
and then there's a deadline of a lesson
or something and you just it's it's a
really uncomfortable experience and
i have arrived at a place where for me
practice is about
like experimenting finding solutions you
can't force something that's not ready
to happen so just meandering around it
trying trying this trying that
and all the while i do have very high
pressure deadlines
however
i whatever i do in the practice room
like that's as far as
i will get with that piece at that time
then i go out and i play it and i learn
something on stage and i'm like okay
there's something else i need to figure
out
let me just do what i can
perform it
that didn't work let's see let's try
this little other idea and
you know that's been such a healthier
process for me
i think about the pressure of practicing
every day from when we're little we were
talking about this earlier
there's nothing i do every day
of my life besides survival things
like i don't want to watch my favorite
movie 100 days in a row
i don't
do anything the same for 365 days of the
year except i do
fortunately have a place to live i have
a bed to sleep in i have food to eat
those are the things i do
every day
and not everyone has access to that so i
recognize that privilege but
practicing is not is not a survival
skill i think we need to keep that in
mind it's a lifelong
experiment
and it's a lifelong pursuit and it's for
you to find out who you are as a
musician without anyone watching you the
pressure is off when you're practicing
that's what practice should be
and so the more i realized that by
reading people's comments doing these
hundred days of practice seasons
the more i realized how important it is
to talk about that
take the pressure off
it's your time to do your thing your way
so that that realization only is recent
for you then because the hundred days
started about five six years ago
oh yeah yeah i think
also watching myself practice and seeing
how
i work because i didn't see how i worked
before
um
and also just growing into who i am as a
musician like i've always been trying to
find my
flow even when i was already performing
full time
yeah always trying to align what i
wanted to do with what i was actually
doing what do i want to communicate
versus what people are hearing from me
so that was what i did in practice that
was what practice was for
so the probably the last question and
then we'll open up to the floor is that
you sounds you just described yourself
in such a serious way and and it just
seems like maybe some of the videos and
some of the projects you've done are
quite are not quite as serious so
for example you appearing on stage with
two set violin hula hooping to and
playing paganini but i double octaved it
how many of you have seen that
so that definitely tells me you have a
great sense of humor and we've been like
laughing throughout all of today so i
take my work really seriously it's a big
responsibility and
there are a lot of people who
save up money to buy tickets for
concerts they
they
save up money to buy records a lot of
people give their time to listen to my
work and i take it
really seriously just to do my
best to create an emotional
connection and emotional experience and
not to have anything
get in the way of that
and that's why i work really hard
but i love music i love performing i
love that feeling
of connecting with everyone i look at
music as a public service even though
it's a business it's called an industry
but it's something that we can provide
for each other i get things from the
audience that i don't get from
you know myself in normal life and
i hope i give things to the audience and
performance like i give
feelings and experiences and moments
with my colleagues
i hope that those are meaningful to
people
and when you get comments from people
like
um well you see someone when they're a
student like years ago i would meet
someone who's kind of my age like a
teenager
meet them after a concert and then
10 years later they're coming to the
concert and then they bring their baby
and then the kid plays an instrument 10
years later they're at the you know and
it's it's nice you realize that you're
part of people's lives and they really
um
you know there's a role that you play in
someone's life and you don't exactly
know what's meaningful to who to whom at
which times
um so i take every performance really
seriously because
um
in every concert there's someone
experiencing
my current feeling
so if i'm honest with my playing and i
really express my feeling that person
who needs that
format to understand that feeling in
themselves or acknowledge that feeling
themselves
that won't be really meaningful for them
there was a concert recently where
i think my colleague and i were super
exhausted and we're like we're gonna get
it together for the concert we're gonna
do it um and then i was like i bet you
there's someone in the audience tonight
who is celebrating a birthday
and then sure enough after the concert
someone was like i my parents got me
this ticket a year ago for my birthday
i've been looking forward to it and here
we are
i've had people tell me that um
you know this particular recording was
playing in their
parents room during hospice and or like
their baby was born to this music and
i'm like i'm just like oh i'm just one
person you know like but
there's this whole continuum of music
and it's
it's really meaningful and to be given
the opportunity to communicate through
this music it's it's a really big deal
that i i don't take lightly so even in
the two set thing
i was practicing it and you know i
but i can keep it going i did i
practiced the looping i didn't just go
out there and do it like i practice at
home
with paganini i practice my paganini
i don't just walk in and like toss
things off but i also love spontaneity
and i love the moment so i just always
try to be prepared for those moments so
that when something important happens i
can just like step into it and absorb
that all that feeling
well i have to say it was really really
fun to be in the audience and all of a
sudden there you were with the hula hoop
no one knew i was watching the show
beforehand either no we did not know and
everyone around us was like losing their
minds oh my god that's hilarion with a
loop so what's she gonna do with the
hulu
it's funny when your name becomes like a
an expression like hillary han like i
don't go through i don't go through life
like
i'm you know walking down the hall i'm
like i'm hilarion
it's like but everyone is like that's
hilarion
hello or miss han or like for me my name
is like two separate words it's like
two said violin hillary han
is that hilarion
that's how we had
it's funny it's really cute i really
appreciate the
acknowledgement
i think on that fun note let's let's
pause and let's hear from the audience
so i do have two of our wonderful aides
or is it just one
okay
so while they get situated so it's
covered so we're not passing the mic
um so i mean if you can go to the other
side that'd be great
and then i think um
yeah i think the idea then is
if you have a question raise your hand
and either andrew or may will come
and just just speak the question that
one of them will speak into the
microphone so don't pass the mic
yeah so it's just just tell him the
question and then
and then may you'll speak into the
microphone
got it yes we have a human amplifier
we're trying to be covered safe so
you're just holding the microphone no no
wait i got it i got it everyone
sit down
you can sit down thank you um and then
you say your question to
your human amplifier who then has he
will repeat yes
thank you
uh while we're over here alvin here has
a question
great okay you're next
so alvin asks if you've ever had any
times that you felt unnerving to play
you know maybe even a little bit
nervous even though you've practiced a
lot uh even despite you know performing
so often over your career
or unmotivated is a caveat to the
question unmotivated to practice
motivated and motivated yeah um
would you like me to talk about the
practice or the performance experience
it was more so like being unmotivated to
play and just like not feeling like you
were
playing with feeling and emotions even
though you've been playing for such a
long time so the gist is like
okay
i did hear that one okay great um so how
do i continue to play with feeling even
unmotivated this is something i've been
working on constantly all of my
life as a musician and i think i finally
landed on something
so maybe i can give you a little tip to
leapfrog you over like 20 years of
figuring it out
um
i play what i'm feeling
in the moment i don't um
i used to think that i should
plan it you know i should practice it
this is how i want to play like my
interpretation of something was a series
of decisions
and a style
but the problem was i kept getting
reviews comments on the youtube videos
um like she sounds robotic it's not
expressive and i'm like i'm pouring
myself into this what's not connecting
i would get reviews constantly about
great technique but kind of reserved
musicality and i just i was like a
puddle at the end of the concert it was
like i was so worn out and i was like
forcing all of the possible emotion in
and i realized i needed to it was only
when i started doing solo bach recitals
for the first time like a few years ago
i never played a solo recital before
because i love working with people
and i didn't feel the need to do a full
solo recital but when i started doing it
as a project
um
i
realized that i was second guessing
myself too much to get through a concert
like i just was
not feeling like i was i was in a very
uncomfortable psychological state when
it was just me
and i was trying to do things i was
trying to do this i was trying to do
that always like judging what i was
doing as i was going
and i just on the third concert i
decided
i'm just gonna stay i was working on
this in the master class a little bit
today so this is a little bit of
background on how i arrived there um
so i just decided i'm just gonna stay on
these notes until i feel like i'm done
with them the whole concert
every note i'm going to be in it
as long as i need to be in it whether
that's shorter than i planned longer
than i planned slower faster
in good taste not in good taste
i am just going to enjoy every note and
not think ahead not think back for an
hour and a half
and
it was so cleansing
and so
um
like
also healing as a musician you're trying
try and try and try and try and you're
like analyzing yourself trying to get
better trying to do this trying to do
that trying to do that did i do it did i
not do it how good was that concert
just to be in every note as it went by
and it took me all of those decades of
experience to be able to do that
and recognize when i was in the right
note at the right time
for myself
but
the reviews were entirely different the
feedback on my social media commentary
totally different and i was like that's
what i needed to do all along i needed
to be in my
space emotionally whatever that was and
so
now
instead of working against whatever's
happening in my day
that idea the show must go on
show must go on because we feel things
not despite things going wrong you have
a flu and you go don't take this like
don't don't go work
whatever but you know when when i was
growing up it's like are you sick can
you perform if you can you go out and do
it despite being sick now it would be
like am i low energy
the show must go on because i'm low
energy
and i'm going to change my energy in the
course of the show so i'll start
performing low energy i'll be like just
not a day where i'm going to play
loud right now i don't have fast in me i
don't have dynamic in me i'm going to
really take this energy down even if
it's like the beginning of the brahms
concerto you know slow it down take your
time
and then at some point you've identified
with that low energy and you're like
okay i'm sick of it let's go
and then then it picks up and you've
completely gone through
your own evolution
with the audience
and you arrived honestly at a different
mood and everyone has been there with
you and
that i think is what is motivating
music is this channel for you rather
than
this despite
this i have to do that
if you can work with it it's amazing and
it's that thing like whatever you're
going through
there's someone out there who hears it
and feels it and needs that so the more
you can just be true to yourself
obviously not
you know
you're working with colleagues you want
to find a way to connect with your
colleagues
and
do that same emotional honesty while
playing i think that it is really a very
very special conversation at that point
you could do that in practice too you
know just take a moment and where am i
emotionally
why why do i feel this resistance what
is going on and don't fix it just like
be with that just notice it's that that
idea of notice what's going on
and just say okay name it notice it name
it leave it alone just do your thing
and i think it it's
yeah then it's not a matter of
motivation it's a matter of like living
through it
i think we have to discuss that you're
so patient
now you can stand up now i understand
what's happening if you want to stand up
you can stand up
hi um
i was just wondering for those like
students who might not necessarily be
pursuing a professional career like
playing music how can we still keep like
music like a daily part of our time
um this may be my
own inclination but i think
we can all make the world
better
by connecting
and
connecting with people we know
connecting with people we don't know
music can be a conduit for a lot of
things
so
i find that
when
i need to keep things moving musically
despite all that because a lot of my
work has nothing to do with playing the
violin
so
i'm always trying to find time to
practice and that's actually why 100
days of practice is good because then
like the work is practicing yes
but you know when you don't have a lot
of time
maybe have an overarching
goal like what are you going to do with
the music what is the music going to
mean for you what's it's going to mean
to the other people in your life what's
it going to mean to the community you
can maybe put together just like a
little goal of some community project
and then the more you collaborate with
people the more you'll be
forced to prioritize the the music and
also you'll get that feedback loop from
you know when you're in school you have
performance opportunities when you're
not you may not have performance
opportunities so create ones that make a
difference for some other people and
then it's not so much about like
delivering the perfect performance from
the stage it's about the purpose of
music everyone has individual ideas so
your idea will be valid
and
you'll be able to
like feel like there's a real point to
it which is very motivating when you
don't have a lot of time
as well that would be my suggestion
um
itself it's still a lot of fun so my
question was going to be um what is your
favorite live performance experience
performance experience
like ever
i'm going to take a two-pronged answer
because there's actually a kind of
performance that evolved during
lockdowns that wound up being a lot more
meaningful to me than
i
had expected but it was not a live
performance situation so i record i
pre-recorded a video of a world premiere
and then it was a global world premiere
it was michael abel's piece isolation
variation
and
it was commissioned as part of a virtual
residency
at my request
and
i got to
watch during the premiere i got to watch
who was tuning in from where around the
world and usually world premieres are
just in a place whoever can get there so
it's really just like a hall premiere
that's the very first one in the world
so it's a world premiere it's not a
global world premiere all at the same
time
and so that and then also
having that video then that i can send
to other
uh virtual performances as a performance
it increases like the reach of
contemporary music it increases the
effectiveness of one performance that i
recorded um
and so that's actually been very special
to me that's the most special
performance out of the
lockdown experience and i think we need
to keep those things going because
there's value in that that we cannot
achieve in a live performance in a hall
obviously live performances are not
replicable virtually
and so we need to keep looking at ways
that are individual to
live performances that strengthen the
the
strengths of live performance and then
other formats that strengthen the
strengths of
virtual connections
for a live performance experience
i think
personally the most enlightening one was
that bach recital where everything
clicked which happened to be
at lincoln center so i was returning to
lincoln center which i played in as a i
played as a teenager and have played at
since i've gone to performances there
but i had the entire
i don't know what they call it anymore
it used to be ellis tully hall and they
renamed it and i was like an old person
so i'm stuck back in ellis tully times
um
but i
was playing and i was the only person
backstage i was the only person on stage
i was the only person um performing and
when they were when i left the hall and
they turned out the lights for the hall
i was like
that was just me
and that was the concert where i stayed
in every note and it was like this
eternity of a super special
moment that just it just drew me through
it
um and then the realization like wow
look where i've landed
you know i think no matter what we
achieve in life it's important to look
at where we are like where do we think
we'd be and where are we now and what
are we proud of right now
um in every class and every conversation
with a student i always ask what are you
proud of because i think we forget to
ask ourselves that
so um yeah i think the moments where
i've been able to really sort of sit
back and be like whoa this is a very
cool thing that music enables those are
probably my favorite performances
thank you
[Laughter]
oh that's so
cool i'll let you select this uh
maybe the person in the jean jacket
that's you yeah
that is that is you
red shirt and jean jacket yes
do you need a mic or a person
you can say it and they can translate it
yeah
okay
living dangerously okay
thank you so much for coming to yale and
giving your talk
it was really wonderful to hear you play
i'm a master student at the school of
music
one of the things that i'm very
passionate about is the intersection of
media and
music and one of your recent projects
was with david lang and involved ai and
i was curious about how that came about
and how you see the future of music
interacting with
the
new forms of media that is currently
emerging and always changing and
and transforming our art form
that was part of a
project that i co-founded so that was
something that i was working on a lot
during
my
part of my sabbatical and also part of
the season that mostly was canceled last
season
there's an ai scientist named carol
o'reilly
who um
she she and i go way back socially and
we have been talking on the phone about
just a brainstorm of like where does
music and ai
overlap and i love talking with people
from different fields and kind of
interpreting their knowledge into a
musical or artistic
spectrum kind of like when i go to a
museum and i see the brush strokes of
the painting or i see like how an artist
sort of dug into the paper with a pen
and i can almost feel it in my hand and
translate it to a bow stroke what would
it feel like to make that art how can i
make the sound
like that visual impression and so i do
that same parallel drawing with other
art forms and i think ai
interestingly
i think this but ai scientists do not
but i think ai is an art form
because
there's a lot of interpretation in
coding
there's a lot of
beauty in
how
ai programs and systems are
structured and ai is at a point right
now with music where a lot of the
foundation code is being written
and
a lot of the ethics are being
established and
so it just seemed like an interesting
thing to explore
let's see where the state of the art
arts
where the state of the art is and
let's see if these composition programs
work for composers on a really high
interpretive level or is it more of a
practical thing and so it was sort of
testing the systems a bit
and it was tricky to find composers who
were interested in that because
in a way when you're composing it's hard
enough without having to learn a new
language of composition having to be
restricted but david has done a lot a
couple other composers were interested
as well so
michael apels actually did a piece that
was uh premiered by dominic kaley
wonderful pianist based in la
and um
i was happy to see that they kept
working together it makes me so happy
when people it's like matchmaking
artistic matchmaking
thing
um
so it was yeah but that project the idea
behind that project was to see
if we could kind of bring the fields
together because they kind of want to be
together
but they kind of don't know how to be
together
like a lot of
a lot of people misunderstand what ai is
and what it can do and what it can't do
and a lot of
people misunderstand what composition is
what it can do what it can't do
but i have found it's actually a lot
harder to get those
those two fields talking to each other
because still
the purposes are at odds
but there are places where they overlap
and so i think that's the direction
we'll probably go
with that that project that that we're
developing it's a little bit in suspense
because
the original idea we had turned out
testing the systems turned out to be
quite complicated
but the pieces that came out of it were
really fun so what david did was he
he input a bunch of his work and then
got the ideas
that the
the program gave him
and
made those into something so he started
the piece that he wrote for me
with the ai's ideas um
he started it with his melody and like
overlapped so he he put an ai note in
between each of his notes so at first
it's the thing that he put in and then
he starts alternating so it's not him
collaborating with
it's them having the similar source
but like kind of
parallel
making making art
and then it ends with just
the notes that the ai was doing so i
think that's a really great idea and
that's something that is very david it's
very david lang
and he's a very open-minded composer and
in fact he was one taking it back full
circle to what we were talking about
with the 27 encores
he was one of the first composers who
was
super
on board with the idea of having
everyone together on that project he's a
very inclusive community builder among
the
composition
all of the composition representatives
these days and he just because he does
bang on a can and all these other
projects
it was really nice to find
people who would
be on board with this experiment who
would struggle with it
and make something really interesting
out of it
does that answer the question
okay
i don't know
that's where we're that's where we
currently are i think people want
projects to have a clear goal
but
sometimes it's the point is like
exploring where can the goal be
so i'm afraid we are actually out of
time so
um can you please all join me in
thanking hillary hawt
[Applause]
[Music]
you